Two weeks ago, the rule was simple: never boil your broccoli, because heat destroys the enzyme that makes its most important molecule.
Today, I am going to tell you to cook your tomatoes.
And the reason those two statements do not contradict each other is the whole point of this video.
A raw tomato is not the best version of a tomato.
Cooking it
The thing everyone tells you destroys nutrients, makes its most valuable molecule several times the house for your body to actually use.
The red in a tomato is a pigment called lycopene.
It belongs to the same family as the beta carotene that makes carrots orange.
But inside a raw tomato, lycopene is not free.
It sits inside structures called chromoplasts, bound into a matrix of protein and membrane.
Your digestion is not good at breaking that open.
Eat a raw tomato, and much of the lycopene passes through you still locked inside the fragments of plant cell it arrived in.
Heat does three things to that.
First, it ruptures the cell walls.
Mechanical release.
The pigment is no longer trapped behind cellulose your enzymes cannot cut.
Second, it denatures the proteins holding the pigment in place, so the molecule comes free rather than staying bound to a structure.
Third, and this is the interesting one, heat changes the shape of the molecule itself.
In a raw tomato, most lycopene is a straight, rod-like form, called the trans isomer.
Heat bends it into cis isomers, and that bent shape packs far more easily into the micelles that carry fat-soluble molecules across your intestinal wall.
Straight molecules stack badly.
Bent ones fit.
so the same amount of lycopene, cooked, reaches your bloodstream in much larger quantities.
In controlled human studies, lycopene from tomato paste was absorbed several times better than lycopene from an equivalent portion of fresh tomatoes.
There is a second multiplier.
Lycopene is fat-soluble, so without fat, there are no micelles waiting for it.
Cooking tomatoes in olive oil is not just flavor.
It completes the delivery system.
Same mechanism we covered with avocado.
The fat is not the nutrient.
The fat is the vehicle.
Now follow it past the intestine.
Absorbed lycopene is packed into chylomicrons, enters the lymphatic system, and reaches your bloodstream.
From there, it transfers into your lipoproteins.
And this is where it gets specific.
Lycopene concentrates inside LDL particles.
That matters.
Because the first step in arterial plaque is not LDL itself.
It is LDL becoming oxidized inside the artery wall.
An oxidized LDL particle is what a macrophage swallows uncontrollably to become a foam cell.
Lycopene riding inside that particle sits exactly where the damage starts.
It also builds up in tissue.
The liver, the adrenal glands, the testes and the prostate hold the highest concentrations in the body.
So what does the evidence say?
Here it splits, and I want to be careful.
On observational data, it is consistent.
People with higher lycopene intake, and more importantly higher lycopene measured in their blood, show lower rates of cardiovascular disease across many populations.
Meta-analyses of those studies agree.
On randomized trials, it is thinner.
Supplementing isolated lycopene has not reliably reproduced the benefits seen in people who eat tomatoes.
That gap usually means one of two things.
Either the whole food matters more than the single molecule, or the association was never fully causal.
We do not yet know which.
On prostate cancer, be skeptical of what you have heard.
The claim was strong in the 1990s, and has been steadily downgraded as better studies arrived.
Regulators now describe that evidence as very limited.
Mechanism.
Strong.
Population data, consistent.
Isolated supplement trials, disappointing.
So, four rules.
One.
Cook them.
Sauce, roasted, stewed, or paste.
The processed form is genuinely the better sauce here, which is rare enough to be worth saying out loud.
Two.
Cook them in oil.
Without fat, the lycopene has no way across.
3.
Tomato paste is the most concentrated lycopene source in an ordinary kitchen.
One spoonful carries more than several fresh tomatoes.
4.
Keep some raw, because cooking does cost you vitamin C.
This is a real trade, not a free upgrade.
cooked for lycopene, raw for vitamin C, and eat both.
Two quick notes.
Very high long-term intake can tint the skin faintly orange.
It is harmless, and it reverses.
And if you have reflux, tomato is a common trigger, which has nothing to do with lycopene and everything to do with acidity.
None of this was really about a tomato.
It was about a molecule that is present but unavailable, and the fact that how you prepare your food decides which of those two it is.
So which molecule should we follow next?
Write a food and an organ in the comments, and we will take it apart, cell by cell.